but a hundred million dollars cannot be
faked
what are people paying you for the
printers the ink what
what is your business so we sell uh we
sell the printers we also sell the
materials that they use and then uh and
then some services
but but the core of what we deliver is a
complete system
a printer that can fit on your tabletop
that can basically take any 3d design
any cad model you might have in your
computer and produce
it in a range of different materials and
and we supply those materials
for you sell the printers you sell the
materials and they were supposed to be
these other two businesses that would
emerge
uh one of them was like a marketplace
right or the other was
software or enterprise software but i
guess what i have to ask you is when i
first saw this
these were nerds and geeks who were
printing christmas ornaments or little
trinkets that had no value in the actual
real world
other than the fact that they were
magically created and it was fascinating
but they really had no value
who's buying these printers and what are
they printing and what value do those
things create in the universe is it
still
hobbyist making trinkets and telling you
they can make you an ornament
for your christmas tree there is a
there's a hobbyist segment
and it emerged about 10 years ago and
that's a lot of what sort of triggered
this wave of hype in 3d printing
because people thought okay now you know
it was used by
industry before now there's uh some sort
of
looks like consumer usage and maybe
it'll be a mass consumer product
um did that happen is there a mess that
didn't happen why do you think it didn't
happen
it didn't happen because uh 3d printer
doesn't do
enough yet to make sense as a as a home
product got it uh that i think the
concept of a 3d printer is it can take
you know it can create any 3d thing any
physical object you might want
and the reality of a 3d printer is that
it can make a lot of different objects
um but not any and it fits in a certain
size and made out of certain materials
and um and then there's also some skills
still involved
in in running them so all these things
sort of put up barriers where
the number of things you might want to
make with it at home it's not quite
there so the friction if i'm unpacking
this is it's still a little bit
complicated a decade or so into this
we're maybe in the second decade well so
we're actually
closer to four decades well i'm talking
about the second decade of consumers
playing with it like when did
consumers start having their first ones
it was the mid 2000s uh
yeah mid late 2000s 2007
i guess i could give you the you know
the the full history started in the 80s
and for most the history of 3d printing
it's been 100 000 and up refrigerator
size piece of capital equipment
any big company that's doing some kind
of product design whether it's ford or
boeing or apple
has been using them since at least the
early 90s
and then they kind of got better
industry slowly grew
and then getting to the late 2000s
people started to make these uh
these desktop home printers and came
under 25k
under 20k then well yeah even thousand
dollar
kits of parts that people were
assembling um
the thing that really kicked it off was
this open source project called reprap
rep rap reprap yeah which stands for r
i r e p r a p rep
rap yeah and what is what's supposed to
that's i think it's supposed to
stand for replicating rapid prototyper
or something the idea was you're it was
a cheap
one that would also be able to print all
of its own parts so it's
self-replicating yeah this is the
basically the skynet of 3d printers
which
made geeks go even more insane for this
they were like oh my god i can buy a 3d
printer
and print a 3d printer it's like
inception of printer it is inception of
printers and is an awesome
powerful idea and i think there's some
like value to that long term
but the reality is you can you know
print a small portion of a 3d printer i
want to get back to the friction you
mentioned earlier
one is too complicated so it's much less
complicated now
there's a lot of software out there for
3d models there's a lot of things you
can download off the internet if you
wanted a
darth vader helmet i'm sure you could go
on the dark web somewhere and find a
little model even though
star wars maybe didn't license it
properly but somebody's made a 3d model
i want to get into that too as well like
if i'm doing
a clay i might as well get into right
now if i was making like a clay
non-commercial uh you know piece of
pottery and i wanted to make a boba fett
helmet or something
like star horse is not going to come
down on me but if you made it
fairly aggressive but yeah this is what
i heard but if you make a boba fett
helmet and put it on a 3d printing site
they're going to come
rain hell on you yeah yeah there's
definitely a lot of new
um or kind of less well trodden legal
territory being uncovered with
uh 3d content because you know there's
certainly laws that govern this kind of
ip
but it's not been really as tested or as
enforced when it comes to 3d models and
so there there's some new ground being
broken there what do the but the reality
is people use 3d printers
uh the bulk of the industry is still
professionals
right and uh but the next part was that
part of what killed the hobbyist
thing was that you couldn't really do
fun ip on it
or it was like underground i don't think
so i think uh just the friction it's a
successful niche in the hobby market you
know
it's a several hundred million dollars
of hobby business
i would just think that if disney made
one of these printers and said
every month we're gonna let you print
out a new character from the star wars
you buy a subscription for whatever 20
bucks a month
you can print out the collectibles and
we're only going to allow
10 000 to be printed each time did
anybody ever try that kind of like
nonsense
there some companies um started going
down that path makerbot
did i think get into some of sort of
like consumer brand
partnerships um but again i think it it
the printers uh weren't and still aren't
producing
enough range of things like you can get
a coarse plastic model that looks like
okay so that was my follow-up to your
friction thing
what is it with the materials that
limits it today i'm an investor in a
company called desktop metal
they do metal which is really expensive
and crazy
but on the consumer side what is the
limitation of the materials now uh
so well in the cons for the consumer you
mentioned like that that that was like
you could only make certain things
because the printer was only able to
print certain materials it's printing
plastic now right yeah
it's a resin or something in little
spools of string
that's one type of 3d printing that's uh
typically called fuse deposition
modeling where you extrude a little
string of plastic
we actually do a different process
called stereolithography which uses
liquid
resin and lasers to build up a part and
we can make much higher resolution much
more high detailed parts
but to you know to answer about the
materials um
they we're working in plastics there's a
huge range of plastics if you look
around this room there's
strong and stiff plastics there's uh
stretchy plastics there's temperature
resistant ones
and all flexible for cables yeah and all
kinds of different properties there
and the range of plastics that all these
things in this room are made out of is
huge there's like hundreds of thousands
of them commercially available in 3d
printing it's a much smaller set of
maybe hundreds
and they're often not quite as good so
you're often trying to like
meet something so that's a big part of
what we do is we're trying to advance
materials technology as well